this is a heavyweight bout this is the
one that you tune in for
obviously like the yankees against the
indians but when you see two matchups
like this
this is pretty special talking about the
two best pitchers in the american league
period just like that the yankees first
and second
with one man out he has to face glebe
torres the cleanup hitter
now he comes to the plate a swing and a
miss
tied him up with a fastball in on his
hands
now that was good pitching there and
bieber went in
on the hands of torres and gobbled them
up
[Music]
here it comes straight three called a
fastball rate down the slot
at 95 miles an hour
so bieber works out of the jam striking
out taurus
and urchella here's cesar hernandez
and that missed the location but it's
strike three hernandez down looking
so that brings up jose ramirez two outs
nobody on here in the bottom of the
first inning
and there's two strikeouts for garrett
cole here in the first inning
aaron hicks will lead off for new york
here's the payoff pitch
swing and a miss he got him to chase a
high fastball
and bieber has struck out three in a row
clint frazier hitless in the series has
walked three times swinging a miss
blew it right by him and beaver is
heating up he has fan four straight
scoreless spot in the second left-hand
hitting eddie rosario will lead off
rosario fran mill reyes
and josh naylor and the 3-2
strike three rosario down looking
strike three took the fastball four
strikeouts in a row for cole
and the payoff swinging in a miss a
hundred miles an hour
strikeout number five for cole the pitch
dude
he minutes
and he did strike three strikeout number
six for coal
but again cole you've seen frustrated at
times with location
this is perfect pitch i mean right on
the inside corner underneath the hands
99 trying to pull the hands in you
just cannot catch up to it there's such
life to that such velocity
when he pinpoints it under your hands no
score as we head to the fourth inning in
downtown cleveland
indians and yankees shane bieber garrett
cole
about what you'd expect shane's got to
be more like corey kluber he's got to be
effective with his commands
like that that's strikeout number five
and all five have come on the fastball
and that's just
perfect paint right at the knees
on the outside corner unbeatable here's
the pitch
and it's swung out and missed strike
three or shella down on strikes
that is number six for shane bieber
and we'll head to the bottom half of the
fourth inning after bieber sets them
down in order
now the yankees like most teams with
ramirez batting from
the left side put that shift on three on
the right side of the infield with odor
the second baseman in shallow right
did they make quality pitches jose hits
a high drive
deep right judges back he's out of room
and it's off in the top of the wall in
and out of his glove
ramirez around second he's on his way to
third he'll go in headlong
with a one-out triple boy that ball
would have been out of the ballpark if
judge wasn't so tall
i think it was over the yellow line but
it hit his glove and came back in
he's looking he wants to see a replay
watch this see if it gets over but
i think his glove and it comes back in
play home run i think that
is a good goal arch he kept it from yes
he sure did
they're going to want to look at it and
they will but
i'm telling you he saved a home run
that was a heck of a play ramirez knew
he had it but he
timed that jump just perfectly
and i mean it hit into the uh the heel
of that glove and it came back on the
field
it's got a it's got to stand the way it
is great effort on on judge's part
to keep it in play it's still going to
be a triple now they have to take
advantage of this
figure really strong scoring
opportunities may be hard to come by
tonight for both sides
indians have one here with less than two
down runner at third
eddie rosario the batter jose ramirez at
third with one out
yankees have the infield in with the
shift on
taking a call third he goes it into left
field and the indian strike first
rbi number 11 for rosario one-nothing
cleveland as they capitalize on the
ramirez triple
well as uh eddie rosario does he he
likes to get after it early with runners
in scoring position
he did him a favor they slowed it down
and gave him a little slider
and he takes it the other way nobody was
on that side of the diamond
there was three over there he didn't try
to pull a pitch
he stayed on it and the indians pushed
that first run across and that's a big
one to do
here are the four things top of the
fifth and yankees now trailing one
nothing
and the axe will send up picks we're in
the fifth inning one nothing
indians that one is driven into right
center field going back rosario on the
track at the wall
sia and a guy with a big glove made of
play and the yankees have tied the score
at one
quick way to get back in the game it
looked like he hit it off the end of the
bat but that
also his reaction looked like he knew he
got it so
big home run for aaron hicks obviously
tying this game up
now two-way here is rugey odor
he drive right center field see ya
home run for odor and the yankees take a
2-1
you lead why the yankees like home runs
and why they played better with home
runs and no door he has a way of
dropping that bat
immediately no doubt about this one this
ball was
a big fly past the bullpen
change up out over the plate that did a
little flip
[Applause]
shane bieber garrett cole locked in a
doozy
and he'll do it again bieber gets out of
the frame the yankee strand a pair
he gave everything he had tonight
[Music]
strike three rosario down looking
strikeout number 10
for cole look at this 99 right on the
outside corner
swing and pop up on the right side
lemayo makes the play in the camera well
for the second half great play by dj la
mayhew hello there dj how are you
now two-way here's a left-handed josh
naylor
swing and a miss what is it he's doing a
big game against another race
he dominates eddie rosario one for three
an rbi
hit back in the fourth close a game out
he had a huge amount of confidence for
him
lofted to left field on the run topman
and the yankees win
two to one so lawizika picks up his
first save
the win goes to cole the yankees for the
first time this year have won three in a
row